ne m'en voulez pas d'avoir osé parler de
ce thème c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne en ce moment alors peut-être
devrais-je ne pas parler de toutes mes
passions sur cette chaîne Youtube mais
ça me démange je peux pas m'en empêcher
on va parler aujourd'hui ça passe
peut-être mieux quand je montre une
image plutôt que de dire le mot
attendez avec vos petits appris horrible
allez on les envoie ailleurs les a
priori les amis aujourd'hui je me suis
rappelé que quand j'étais petit
j'apprécie les dominos et j'ai pas pu en
faire est-ce que je rattrape des crises
qui se sont passées il y a 15 ans dans
ma vie oui en 2001 2002 2004 et 2005 sur
TF1 qu'est-ce qui a fait une audience de
plusieurs millions de téléspectateurs
[Musique]
domino day c'est quoi les plus jeunes
d'entre vous se souviendront pas mais
les gens comme mon âge donc ils sont
plus vieux vous vous souviendrez domino
day les amis c'était une émission
annuelle dans laquelle il y avait des
parcours de dominos gigantesque avec
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
dominos et c'était plusieurs centaines
de bénévoles qui préparaient le parcours
pendant 2 à 3 mois avant l'émission
C'est fou de dépenser autant d'énergie
dans la confection de parcours de
dominos pourquoi ça s'est perdu c'est
génial je vais pas faire le mec je suis
pas un méga fan de Domino j'ai pas des
t-shirts domino et je fais pas des
dominos une fois par semaine mais je
trouve que c'est le truc le plus
satisfaisant du monde
vous avez des problèmes dans la vie
regardez des vidéos dominants c'est la
dernière strate si après ça vous êtes
toujours pas convaincu je ne pourrais
plus rien faire passer une autre vidéo
mais c'est dommage parce qu'on va en
faire ici tous ensemble juste après oh
là là on a tout de suite ça fait plaisir
bref c'est un peu comme la vidéo qu'on a
fait ou je tentais des structures en
ballon gonflables c'est un truc qui a
notre échelle individuel de gens qui ont
pas trop tard là-dedans et qui découvre
n'est pas très impressionnant mais quand
tu regardes ce que les champions du
monde de Domino ou de structure de
ballon fond ça rentre dans la catégorie
de c'est de l'art en fait carrément
tellement c'est incroyable d'ailleurs
après ma vidéo sur les ballons vous avez
été plein d'envoyer des images de
structures incroyable faites en ballon
et mec c'est trop impressionnant et bah
les dominos c'est la même chose donc je
propose qu'on regarde quelques vidéos de
gens très fort et qu'ensuite on s'y
colle alors sur Youtube le roi du domino
Game c'est domino King
c'est pas une blague lui il fait pas des
parcours à sensations il fait ce qu'on
appelle du du dessin je sais pas comment
on appelle ça ok je viens de trouver un
terme qui ne définit probablement pas du
tout ce qu'il fait voilà par exemple là
il a fait un petit SpongeBob regardez
c'est impressionnant voilà il y a un
truc très flou et en fait ça fait tomber
les couleurs au bon endroit et du coup
le le dessin apparaît c'est fou les
feuilles il est génial je pourrais
regarder ça en fait le moment où les
dominos tombent et où dessin à Paris
bien c'est tellement satisfaisant c'est
un truc de oh
c'est incroyable effet que ça fait je
suis vraiment en train d'essayer de
ramener le domino à la mode c'est un
gros pari mais j'ai envie
oh non c'est incroyable
la taille oh non et
l'autre sens ah non il a mis
il a juste inversé le sens de la vidéo
peut-être ne suis-je pas très objectif
finalement ok vous êtes pas convaincu et
ben maintenant on va regarder des
parcours mecs c'est marrant parce que
cette vidéo en vrai je l'ai vu il y a
juste après qu'elle soit sortie je crois
elle est devenue un peu virale oui une
vidéo de domino qui devient virale donc
la baisse quelqu'un qui a des packs de
Domino les mêmes que j'ai commandé là et
qu'on va utiliser mais par contre cette
personne a un truc que je n'ai pas c'est
le talent pour faire des parcours de
Domino regardez combien de boîtes de
dominosa regardez tous les accessoires
qu'il y a ça commence déjà par une
toupie c'est une toupie qui déclenche le
premier domino le level il est très haut
là c'est une guillotine qui envoie une
boule sur des dominants c'est une
tyrolienne qui déclenche une autre série
de dominante et là c'est parti elle est
ratée parce que les boules ne sont pas
attrapées par les dinosaures et j'ai vu
dans les commentaires des gens être
vraiment très déçu premier degré que ça
a raté genre vraiment les gens étaient
en colère les gens râler vraiment pour
les degrés c'est incroyable je sais que
là c'est d'un coup vous prenez du recul
sur la vidéo vous vous dites mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur la chaîne
c'est normal mais on assume nous on est
plein à apprécier ce qui se passe et on
est vraiment bien les loopings
extraordinaire oh ça va décoller
c'est fou j'espère que vous êtes un peu
sensible [ __ ] et j'ai découvert un
truc qui est trop drôle mec c'est les
dominos géants mais c'est pas genre
juste des parcours de Domino géants ça
commence tout petit et ça finit immense
il a peur du bruit que fait le dernier
la prochaine mec j'ai eu un fou rire
quand je l'ai vu je suis honnête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la prochaine étape mec c'est
le dernier domino c'est un immeuble ça
me fume mec bon on a regardé vous êtes
un peu au courant de ce qui se passe
dans le domino game de ce que c'est de
ce qu'il est possible de faire et
maintenant temps de passer en mode
activité manuelle et vous savez que je
suis une sacrée merde voilà évidemment
j'ai déjà trié un peu les boîtes ici on
a plein de dominos et on va pouvoir
faire des du
[Musique]
non c'est pas agréable mais je vous jure
que après ça va aller j'ai acheté des
parcours comme ça là et du genre dedans
il y a des accessoires vous voyez qui
sont un peu qui changent un peu juste du
trait domino classique que mon vois mais
on va commencer par un trait domino
classique j'ai 4 ans et demi c'est
effrayant ok les amis des temps de faire
ensemble notre premier rail de Domino
évidemment
pas d'accessoire juste nous nos mains et
les dominos et la satisfaction à la clé
évidemment qui sera notre récompense si
quelqu'un me voit il va se dire je suis
en burn out mec complet alors que non
j'aime bien est-ce que vous êtes prêts
j'ai envie qu'il se remette
instantanément droit et de leur faire
c'est chiant la phase de ça là attendez
mais est-ce que je serais pas en train
d'avancer une transition pour la suite
de ma vidéo là les amis on a plus 8 ans
et quand on a plus 8 ans on gagne sa vie
et quand on gagne sa vie on achète ceci
oui
[Musique]
la jalousie est un sentiment normal face
à ce que vous êtes en train de voir il
y a pas de
[Applaudissements]
grosse [ __ ]
[Musique]
ok maintenant faut relier les lignes ta
pitié pas de fausse manip je vous
impressionner dès le premier truc qu'on
fait ah oui en fait c'est pas sponso si
certains avaient des doutes et qui se
disait bon il a peut-être touché une
somme folle finalement non non ouais
mais non ok plus que là-bas
[Musique]
une belle réussite
c'est trop bien je suis en train de
devenir foot tout ça dans mon studio ok
là laisse-moi vous présenter tout ce que
j'ai dans mon garage première accessoire
ah bon on met des dominos dessus et ça
crée un peu de verticalité dans une
dimension qui de base est très
horizontale est-ce que j'utilise des
termes beaucoup trop sérieux pour ce
sujet non c'est sérieux ce qui se passe
ah le truc vert il faut qu'un domino
tombe sur ceci et ensuite ça fait partir
une bille d'ici qui va jusqu'en bas et
qui déclenche un autre domino à
l'arrivée vraiment impressionnant
n'est-ce pas ça c'est des rails auxquels
on va accrocher les dominos et qui font
partie d'un parcours bien précis à
l'issue duquel se trouve un looping
mais cela voici grosso modo comme
assemblé le parcours il y aura deux
looping deux tours ouvertes et le petit
Bridge qui est là et ça va être de la
balle bébé mais avant tout la difficulté
va être dévaluée ou va la voiture
vraiment pas lourd allez taper la chaîne
Cala qui va là qui va là qu'on voit ça
là qui continue oh c'est incroyable oh
ça y est ça y est je m'y colle je vous
raconte le parcours dès qu'il est prêt
au charbon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on arrive bientôt au bout là lâchez que
vous avez un plus que jamais de voir si
ça va marcher que vous espérez
secrètement que ça marche pas pour voir
ma réaction de mec dépité parce que vous
vous nourrissez mes frustrations et de
mes peurs et de ma colère vous avez bien
raison bon franchement on a un beau
parcours je suis assez fier là il me
reste juste à placer les dominos sur les
escaliers et ensuite à amorcer les trucs
qui lancent les voitures ça ça va être
la partie technique parce que ces trucs
là ça a l'air d'être des vrais
fourberies on va déjà faire ce truc là
bas
j'ai l'impression d'être à Fort Boyard
dans les épreuves d'agilité de merde là
vous savez ça
[ __ ] tellement dangereux si j'en fais
tomber un ça va tout gâcher
ok ça c'est fait plus qu'à amorcer les
machines de la mort là-bas
celui-là il est amorcé il y a plus qu'à
mettre les voitures en place mais avant
ça j'aimerais vous dire qu'il y a une
zone à risque il y a une erreur dans le
parcours il y a une erreur de conception
d'ingénierie et c'est ma photo ok
j'accepte les responsabilités qui vont
avec c'est qu'en fait là la voiture elle
doit passer au dessus de ça pour aller
shooter là mais elle va sûrement shooter
un domino qui alla donc le pire scénario
sur X2 minola il chute celui-là qui
chute celui-là du coup le parcours
continue ici alors qu'il n'est pas passé
par là comme prévu donc voilà j'espère
que ça va marcher oh faut que je place
la biche je fais oublier la bille oh
[ __ ] je stresse
mec les voitures j'ai failli oublier les
voitures
ok ok tout est bien en place je vais
procéder au déclenchement
ça devrait aller je sais pas si je filme
bien gère deux caméras peut-être c'est
la merde mais en tout cas ce qu'on vit
c'est un grand moment c'est mon premier
vrai parcours de domino qui sera
peut-être le dernier selon l'issue de
celui-ci j'ai tout donné j'ai tout
calculé alors je vais pas désamorcer un
potentiel échec parce qu'il y aura pas
d'échec c'est parti
[Musique]
tu es jaloux mon petit pote ah tu es
jaloux toi petit rageux va c'était court
mais intense comme toutes les fois qu'on
suivent la première les amis c'est la
fin de cette vidéo je suis heureux j'ai
fait un parcours de Domino le même que
les enfants de 8 ans font après avoir
reçu ses cadeaux là à Noël quelle chance
je suis trop content
[Musique]